♪ ♪
>> I WILL BE HOLDING A NUMBER OF
DISCUSSIONS WITH STUDENTS, LOCAL
LEADERS, AND LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
DEVELOP CONCRETE STEPS THAT WE
CAN TAKE TO SECURE OUR SCHOOLS,
SAFEGUARD OUR STUDENTS, AND
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES.
JUST A FEW MOMENTS AGO, I SIGNED
A MEMORANDUM DIRECTING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO PROPOSE
REGULATIONS TO BAN ALL DEVICES
THAT TURN LEGAL WEAPONS INTO
MACHINE GUNS.
WE CANNOT MERELY TAKE ACTIONS
THAT MAKE US FEEL LIKE WE ARE
MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
WE MUST ACTUALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY
CALLING FOR A CHANGE IN THE
RULON BUMP STOCKS.
THESE ARE THE ADDITIONS TO GUNS
USED IN THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTING,
NOT IN THE FLORIDA SHOOTING, TO
MAKE IT ESSENTIALLY COME AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID, AN AUTOMATIC
WEAPON.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
YOU SEE A PICTURE OF IT.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT RELEASING A
STATEMENT.
"THE DEPARTMENT UNDERSTANDS THIS
IS A PRIORITY FOR THE PRESIDENT
AND HAS ACTED QUICKLY TO MOVE
THROUGH THE RULE MAKING PROCESS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE RESULT OF
THAT PROCESS AS SOON AS ITS DULY
COMPLETED."
"WASHINGTON POST" AND ABC HAVE A
PULLOUT AFTER THE SHOOTING IN
FLORIDA SAYING DOING ENOUGH TO
PREVENT MASS SHOOTINGS.
CONGRESS AT 19%.
PRESIDENT AVENUE 29%.
AT LEAST IN THE POLLS, THERE'S A
LOT OF MOMENTUM TO DO MORE.
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL.
STEVE HAYES, EDITOR IN CHIEF OF
"THE WEEKLY STANDARD."
CHARLES LANE, OPENING WRITER FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
CHARLES HURT, OPINION EDITOR FOR
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES."
CAME AS A SURPRISE TODAY, THE
BUMP STOCK ANNOUNCEMENT.
WHAT DOES IT PORTEND TO THE
MEETINGS AHEAD?
>> IT'S HARD TO TELL WHAT IT
MEANS AND WHERE THE BROADER
DEBATE IS GOING.
IF YOU LOOK BACK BEFORE THE NEW
YEAR, REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
HAD CONSIDERED TAKING SOME
MEASURES LIKE THIS LEGISLATIVELY
AND OPTED NOT TO.
I THINK THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT STEPPED UP SUGGEST
THERE IS CONSENSUS ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE OR AT LEAST
STRONGER AGREEMENT THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING OUGHT TO BE LOOKED AT.
IN TERMS OF THE BROADER DEBATE,
DEMOCRATS ARE, AS THEY OFTEN DO,
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE NRA AND
REPUBLICANS, THE MEDIA IS
OBSESSED WITH THE ARGUMENT
REPUBLICANS ARE CONTROLLED BY
THE NRA.
REALLY THE PROBLEM I THINK
SUGGEST IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
AN ASSAULT WEAPON BAN OR
FAR-REACHING EFFORTS BEING
DISCUSSED, THE PROBLEM IS ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
IF YOU LOOK BACK AT THE 2013
VOTE ON THE ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN,
YOUR 15 DEMOCRATS WHO VOTED,
INCLUDING BLUE STATE DEMOCRATS,
WHO VOTED AGAINST THE ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN.
60-40 VOTE IN A SENATE
CONTROLLED BY DEMOCRATS.
DEMOCRATS AT THIS POINT ARE THE
ONES WHO ARE GOING TO HAVE TO --
IF THEY WANT TO START TO WIN
POLITICALLY ON THIS ISSUE,
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PRIMARY
DEMOCRATS.
>> Bret: THE REASON THIS IS A
BECAUSE CONGRESS DIDN'T TAKE IT
UP.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAID AFTER THE
LAS VEGAS SHOOTING THIS IS THE
ONE TO DO AROUND THE EDGES, IT'S
THE PRESIDENT WHO IS MOVING THE
BALL.
>> YES AND I THINK TO YOUR
ORIGINAL QUESTION, WHAT DOES IT
MEAN, IT RAISES THE QUESTION OF
HOW SUBSTANTIAL A RULE IS GOING
TO END UP BEING.
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
IT WAS THOUGHT IN THE ATF THERE
WASN'T ENOUGH STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO ENACT IT BY
REGULATION WHICH PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS GOING TO ATTEMPT TO DO.
THAT TELLS ME SOMEWHERE DOWN THE
LINE SOMEBODY IS GOING TO SUE
OVER THIS IF IT'S NOT ACTUALLY
ENACTED INTO LAW.
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN,
DEMOCRAT OF CALIFORNIA, CALLING
FOR A STATUTE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THERE
SHOULDN'T BE A STATUTE UNLESS
THE ONLY THING THAT'S GOING ON
HERE IS PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
FEELING UNDER PRESSURE UNDER GUN
CONTROL AND HE'S GOT TO DO
SOMETHING REALLY QUICKLY.
STEVE MAKES AN ASTUTE POINT
ABOUT DEMOCRATS.
THERE IS A DILEMMA FOR THEM
POLITICALLY.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S A SPECIAL
ELECTION GOING ON IN WESTERN
PENNSYLVANIA, TRUMP COUNTRY.
THE DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE FOR
THAT SEAT IS RUNNING AS A
PRO-GUN WESTERN PENNSYLVANIA
DEMOCRAT.
SOME OF THESE RED STATES, THE
SENATE CANDIDATES ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE ARE TORN AS
WELL.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS I'M
VERY SKEPTICAL OF SUBSTANTIAL
GUN-CONTROL COMING OUT OF THIS.
>> THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN THE
PROBLEM WITH THE ACCUSATION THAT
THESE PEOPLE ARE BEHOLDEN TO THE
NRA.
THE TRUTH IS IT'S NOT THAT
POLITICIANS ARE BEHOLDEN TO THE
NRA.
THEY ARE BEHOLDEN TO VOTERS WHO
DON'T WANT TO LOSE THEIR GUN
RIGHTS.
ANY BUMP STOCKS ON SHELVES AFTER
THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTING ARE
FLYING OFF THE SHELVES RIGHT
NOW.
ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK A LOT
OF PEOPLE MISS ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE
LOVE ABOUT GUNS.
THEY LOVE THEIR BRILLIANT
MECHANIC INGENUITY THAT GOES
INTO THEM.
THEY ARE COMPLEX, BEAUTIFUL,
GRACEFUL MACHINES.
THAT'S HOW THE BUMP STOCK CAME
AROUND.
AS YOU POINT OUT, THE QUESTIONS
WILL BE HOW BROAD IS IT?
WHOEVER CAME UP WITH THE BUMP
STOCK CAN EASILY COME UP WITH
SOMETHING ELSE THAT DOES THE
SAME THING.
>> I THINK WHAT THAT GUY IN
LAS VEGAS LOVED ABOUT IT WAS HOW
IT ENABLED HIM TO KILL 50
PEOPLE.
I THINK WE ARE NOW REACHING THE
POINT, WHAT MAY BE CHANGING IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, IS THAT
THIS IS -- THERE IS A LEVEL OF
OUTRAGE NOW.
SLAUGHTERS AND MASSACRES.
IT'S A NATIONAL EMBARRASSMENT
AND I THINK THE FACT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP FELT PRESSURE TO
MOVE SHOWS THE BEAUTY OF THE GUN
AND THE SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHT
IS STARTING TO LOSE ITS HOLD A
LITTLE BIT AT THE MARGINS.
>> THE FACT THAT IT WAS AN EASY
THING -- WASN'T A BIG GUN
COMPANY THAT CAME UP WITH THE
BUMP STOCK.
PEOPLE WERE FIDDLING WITH GUNS.
IF PEOPLE KNOW HOW TO DO THIS,
OTHER PEOPLE CAN RECREATE IT.
>> Bret: THIS WEEK HE IS GOING
TO MEET WITH SEVERAL DIFFERENT
GROUPS ON THE ISSUE OF GUN
CONTROL BROADLY AND ALSO
STOPPING SCHOOL SHOOTINGS,
INCREASING SECURITY AT SCHOOLS.
HERE IS THE REPUBLICAN FROM
FLORIDA AND SARAH SANDERS TODAY.
>> WE NEED TO STRENGTHEN
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS FOR
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS BUT WE
CLEARLY HAVE TO DO MORE TO MAKE
SURE GUNS STAY OUT OF THE HANDS
OF THOSE WHO WANT TO HARM
INNOCENT PEOPLE.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS EXPRESSED
HIS SUPPORT FOR EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE THE FEDERAL BACKGROUND
CHECK SYSTEM AND IN THE COMING
DAYS WE WILL CONTINUE TO EXPLORE
WAYS TO ENSURE THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY IN OUR SCHOOLS.
>> THERE IS A GROWING INTEREST.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS ARE SAYING
YES, SOME CHANGES ARE COMMON
SENSE.
>> Bret: I GUESS IT'S A
DIFFERENT TONE.
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD THIS KIND OF
TONE I DON'T THINK EVER.
>> NO, I THINK THERE IS A NEW
TONE.
THAT'S PRETTY BROAD, WHAT THEY
ARE SAYING.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A LOOK AT
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WE HAVE HEARD THAT BEFORE.
WE HAVE HEARD THAT AFTER EVERY
ONE OF THESE.
THE QUESTION WILL BE WHEN YOU
LAY OUT THE DETAILS OF WHAT THE
CHANGES WILL BE, IF WE EVER GET
TO THAT POINT, IS IT SOMETHING
REPUBLICANS WILL EMBRACE AT THAT
POINT?
AS CHARLIE ARGUES, IS IT
SOMETHING GUN OWNERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WILL EMBRACE?
>> I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WOULD
DISAGREE WITH THE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO DO MORE ABOUT MAKING
SURE PEOPLE WHO SHOULDN'T HAVE
GUNS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO GET GUNS
GUNS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO GET GUN
GUNS.
WHETHER IT'S THE GUY IN
LAS VEGAS OR THIS GUY IN
FLORIDA.
YOU HAVE POLICE COMING TO HIS
HOUSE 39 TIMES IN ONE YEAR.
AND YOU CAN'T TELL ME THERE
ISN'T ENOUGH THERE --
IF THEY REPORT ABOUT HIM
SHOOTING FROM HIS NEIGHBOR'S
CHICKENS.
WHERE I AM FROM, THAT'S A
FELONY.
YOU ARE SHOOTING ON SOMEONE